la variante omicron avanza a gran
velocidad por europa en francia el
gobierno ya ha advertido que será
predominante entre navidad y fin de año
para cuando podría superar los 100 mil
contagios diarios un anuncio que llega
en paralelo al inicio de la campaña de
inmunización de los niños de 5 a 11 años
son agilización si es un 20 por ciento a
nivel nacional eso significa que fue un
10 por ciento hace dos días y un 5 por
ciento hace un día lo que se alinea con
el inicio de la oleada de omicron eso
significaría que en dos días estaremos
un 35 o 40 por ciento y en 4 a 5 días
justo después de navidad con toda
probabilidad sería la variante
predominante en nuestro país en la misma
línea de preocupación
alemania impuso nuevas restricciones por
la presencia de omicron que entraran en
vigor el 28 de diciembre momento en el
que se prohibirán las reuniones de más
de 10 personas incluso si están
vacunados los grandes eventos incluyendo
partidos de fútbol se realizarán sin
público
con el fin de terminar con todo esto de
una vez creo que sería bueno otro
confinamiento para que podamos celebrar
otra vez la fila est algo en dirección
contraria a lo que planea inglaterra que
no aplicarán nuevas restricciones por
navidad' aunque apela a la prevención
y
seguimos vigilando omicron muy de cerca
y si la situación se deteriora estaremos
preparados para tomar medidas si es
necesario lo que significa que la gente
puede seguir adelante con sus planes de
navidad pero la situación sigue en una
balanza y pido a todo el mundo
precaución
escuche el distanciamiento social
volverá a suecia donde también han
urgido a los empleados a volver al
teletrabajo en dinamarca y finlandia
habrá restricciones en lugares públicos
medidas que buscan en mitigar la
propagación del virus y evitar caer en
un nuevo confinamiento como el que ya
rige en países bajos hasta el 14 de
enero